china's economy is struggling right now
chinese second quarter gdp growing at
the slowest pace since 2020 and its
government could be setting up a series
of stimulus measures to help the country
avoid a major slowdown in growth i'm
going to explain the problems we're
seeing from the chinese economy what the
country's leaders are doing to try to
contain the damage and why these issues
could be a problem for the us and the
rest of the global economy second
quarter gdp growth 0.4 percent much
worse than expected and that now cements
the idea that the government has no
chance of meeting its five and a half
percent growth target this year the
biggest issues facing china right now
are largely the result of government
crackdowns in an effort to slow
speculation and debt accumulation china
instituted new rules in the housing
market limiting lending and land sales
under the government mantra housing is
for living not for speculation the
government has been aggressively
enforcing its zero tolerance policy on
covet 19 outbreaks instituting mandatory
lockdowns and testing whenever a new
case is discovered chinese communist
party officials have also taken aim in
the country's tech sector cracking down
on planned expansions and breaking up
companies deemed too large or powerful
in addition to government crackdowns
china is experiencing a generational
heat wave and drought that have clipped
the country's hydroelectric power and it
will already see slow down in production
in the steel industry and chemical
industry in fertilizer industry and
those are very important things when it
comes to construction to agriculture and
also to manufacturing in general all of
that has led to dramatic write-downs for
growth expectations this year and pushed
policy makers to take steps to buoy the
economy the people's bank of china has
lowered lending rates multiple times
this year and the government has
introduced hundreds of billions of
dollars in stimulus measures in august
beijing announced a 19-point stimulus
plan to boost the economy that followed
a 33-point plan announced in may that
was designed to stabilize the economy
but china's economy is still struggling
and as the world's number one trading
nation its weak growth could add to
problems for the u.s and other countries
around the globe to us the most
important factor outside of the xero
cove situation is actually the housing
the dramatic slowdown in its real estate
market is slowing demand for raw
materials and the shutdown in parts of
its shipping industry is holding up
global supplies chinese companies have
received billions in loans and
investments from wall street that may
not be paid back if firms go under
china's financial sector is becoming
much more tied to the rest of the world
and could add to struggles american
markets are facing with inflation
slowing growth and aggressive policy
from central banks the us which is a
major consumer of chinese products and
has much of its economy supported by the
financial sector could really suffer
it's like de la soul said back in 2000
your people might have your back but you
need to watch your front indeed
and nothing guaranteed
that's all for now see you next time
you